well I just don't think anybody else
could win if Trump runs so and I don't I
just really you think if they got on a
stage you you don't think that the
scientist is is Crafty enough or the
record stands enough to really
interesting I don't even think that a
little
while down here obviously in Florida now
and it's been a little hard for me to
try to figure out what's going on with
the mainstream media when it comes to
this hurricane but it's pretty obvious
because I don't have cable anymore so I
can't you know I only see Twitter clips
now but it's pretty obvious it's like
these this this machine would love for
This Disaster to have been worse to to
get to santis do you think that's too
much to say that or do you agree with
that no it's oh oh my God no it's
definitely not too much the media is
capable of anything the darkest things
you can possibly imagine they're capable
of it they're very agenda driven so yes
and what they're doing to sand us now in
Lee County it was like why didn't you
cover Lee County he's like well the
course of the hurricane changed and when
it changed we gave an evacuation order
and they're like but it takes 20 hours
for the people on the outskirts to
evacuate well take it up with hurricane
Ian right and to desantis's credit he
said to the media where were you you
weren't in Lee right you guys were all
in Tampa you were in Tampa so like save
it but if they smell smell in the water
you know they're gonna they love it when
it's a Republican and there was just a
report I think I think it was Maggie
Haberman in the New York Times who was
saying something like a lot of the times
you have to wait you have to wait to see
the damage to know what kind of a job
the leader has done so it's basically
like so far he's done a good job but
just let's hold our fire because I'm
sure there'll be disasters popping up
that we can blame on him later
it really it's it's so gross it really
is just so absolutely gross what do you
want to happen with the Trump DeSantis
thing
well I just don't think anybody else
could win if Trump runs so and I don't I
just really I know you think if they got
on a stage you you don't think that the
scientist is is Crafty enough or the
record stands enough to really
interesting I don't even think that a
little
um I think Trump sucks up all the energy
in every room no matter what and even
someone is skilled as a politician and
smart policy wise as DeSantis can't
overcome that he can't
it the only way DeSantis is going to
become the Republican nominee is if
Trump chooses not to run and endorses
him or dies
like I just don't see a world in which
Trump says I want it
let's say he says I want it and DeSantis
beats him fair and square in the primary
you really think the hardcore Maga is
going to abandon Trump for DeSantis
they're not I talk to them all the time
I I take calls from them on my radio
show and they won't they they like
DeSantis but they don't think it's his
turn they think Trump was screwed out of
his last election that he was screwed
out of his first term by all the
craziness of the Russia gate and so on
and they think he's he is entitled he
deserves another shot at it and so
unless Trump
gracefully and graciously says Get
Behind DeSantis I I wouldn't put any
chips on DeSantis at all
that's that's really interesting I mean
look I I've said many times I'd love
love for them to work it out on the deal
have a dinner figure out what has to be
figured out and go forward a lot of
people and I'm sort of moving on this a
little bit say that they should just get
on the debate stage and do it and and
whoever you know comes out will be
sharper for it
um but I agree there is a certain
portion of like the base base that would
rather burn everything down if if it
doesn't get to Trump but it's huge
portion Dave it's a huge portion like
the hardcore Trump Faithful Is
unshakable and there I again I hear from
them all the time they're they like him
they like DeSantis but they would never
cross Trump for him and they think that
DeSantis owes his political career to
Trump like if forced to choose they will
choose Trump so DeSantis can't take him
down it's like the line in war games the
only winning move is not to play
DeSantis has got to either be crowned by
Trump
um or you shouldn't run he's he's Trump
it'll it would be
I I don't know I don't he it wouldn't I
was gonna say it's not gonna be a
Kamikaze Mission because he wouldn't
take down Trump right only Trump can
take down Trump
um but he won't win over Trump I I'll
stand by that you can play it against me
if I'm wrong but I won't be by the way
I'm not even totally sure I want him to
run I I love Florida so much and I know
how much he loves it and I know how this
state is flourishing that at some level
just at a I suppose a somewhat selfish
level it's like no stay here let's let's
keep running with this thing and see how
great we can make this state and maybe
the Machinery of the federal government
is just so broken that Swamp Thing maybe
is so all-encompassing that there's not
much you could do there anyway it
wouldn't be bad
to vote for gridlock
yeah it wouldn't be bad to just freeze
the executive's powers which have gotten
too big yeah and this this version of of
the presidency of the executive branch
was never envisioned by the founders
it's gotten too big and too out of
control however
if we froze it as it is now if we're
voting for gridlock from you know in
2024 or 2022 and 2024 and Beyond well
then we're going to be stuck with a lot
of bad Biden policies and I I would love
to see some of those reversed for
example due process for young men
accused on college campuses which is
about to switch back to Biden's and
Obama's worldview unless this public
comment period which was very anti-
their changes changes things but
you know he doesn't want due process for
accused men on campuses he wants trans
girls to be competing against biological
girls and girls Sports there's a lot of
stuff that Biden's done that needs to be
undone and then if we could just like
undo it and put us back to stasis
then I'm all for good luck you know I I
don't want a big executive I'd much
rather see Governors make policy and you
know do police power things and so on
so since you can say whatever you think
about all sorts of stuff these days and
you mentioned Biden
do you think he's all there what do you
think is really going on here at this
point who do you think is running this
thing it cannot be him right
Joe Biden is not okay
there's no question in my mind all the
signs of dementia are present and
increasing it's getting worse by the day
the being lost all the time that's a
sign the increase in slurrence featuring
so hold on to understand that's a sign
of dementia
the inability to remember who's dead and
who's alive even though moments earlier
you saw a tribute to this representative
from Indiana Jackie wolorski and then
you look around the room and say where
is she you just you just saw a tribute
you wrote a letter to her family I
realized he didn't do it he knew she was
dead he'd been told it wasn't just a few
weeks it was two months earlier he
forgot it's a sign of dementia
um all even
the way we mock how he says something
and then the White House comes out a day
later and does the cleanup you know like
no no we're not gonna go into Taiwan if
China invades we're not yeah that's
that's not and uh it depends on if it's
a minor incursion and oh no I'm former
regime change in Russia all three you
know right his his minions at the White
House or his controllers run out and say
didn't mean it not a change in policy
that's part of it he's not in control of
what he says of what he blurts out and
he's the one who in that 60 Minutes Dave
said watch me yep the question by Scott
Pelley was are you fit and he said to us
watch me
well we have we are and we're deeply
alarmed we're coming up on November
that's when the annual physical is there
must be a cognitive test the results of
which must be publicly released Trump
did it in 18 and Biden has to do it and
it better be with somebody who we trust
and not some hack
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about the media
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our media playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics check out the full episode
playlist they're both right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification Bell